thanks Jared and I'm excited to be here
I'm one of those people who have been
here for the last 4 years
so this conference is always one of the
highlights of the spring for me and the
talk I'm gonna give today is actually
really specially tied into this New York
City Art conference because I'm gonna be
talking about my experience working in
healthcare technology and accelerating
cancer research using our and in
particular I'm going to talk about some
of the challenges that that we faced at
the company I work for Flatiron Health
over the last few years both as a
smaller start-up which was a talk I gave
in this very stage two years ago I
talked about the first year and some of
the challenges we encountered using our
and so today I'm gonna refresh some of
that material that I presented two years
ago and then tell you what has happened
in the last two years and what the next
set of challenges we face are and so a
little bit about me in my background so
I come from a world of academic
biostatistics and first in graduate
school and then as a faculty member at
Cleveland Clinic and so some of the the
work that I did there was really focused
on using our I was working pretty
independently so I could use whatever
language I wanted for the most part a
few times in grad school I used sass
under duress but I mostly I used our and
I was coding by myself you know for
better or for worse a lot of academics
are working pretty independently so no
one was really reviewing my code I
didn't have to follow any standards I
just wanted to get the research right
and so after doing that for a few years
as Jared mentioned I he convinced me to
move to New York from Cleveland and I
joined a healthcare tech company called
Flatiron healthcare because I was
interested in a faster pace and a
potential for more immediate impact to
my work and so once I got to Flatiron
things changed in terms of the technical
environment I was in it wasn't just I
use whatever I wanted to get the job
done now I'm in this environment that is
a tech companies so there are many
software engineers using Python all of
the data lived in relational data
so we used variants of sequel some of my
co-workers at the time you SAS - I
obviously wanted to use our but it
wasn't really as clear-cut of a decision
as it was in the past so before I get
into you how we made some of these
decisions over time just want to tell
you a little bit about what we do at the
company to give some some context so our
mission is to improve lives by learning
from the experience of every cancer
patient so my task well every cancer
patient we're not doing that already and
the answer's no so right now about only
5% or so of cancer patients are enrolled
in clinical trials the other about 95%
are going to their oncologist they're
getting some kinds of treatment and some
of them are getting better and some of
them are getting worse and unfortunately
a lot of that information isn't really
getting used for research so it's being
captured in an electronic health record
but the format that it's being captured
and being siloed in different locations
and not being standardized it's just not
necessarily research-grade data so right
now for the most part we're not learning
from the experience of that 95% of
cancer patients and so that's what I've
been working on the last few years as
well as my my co-workers trying to
process some of this oncology based EHR
data at scale and so how do we do that
we don't look at the structured data so
those are discrete fields that actually
have standardized data inputs things
like demographics and diagnosis and and
labs but yet they still need to be
standardized and harmonized they're
messy and complex on their own in their
raw form we also take unstructured data
so those are things that live in things
like physician notes radiology reports
free text it could be in a you know a a
scanned document that's scanned at 45
degrees and handwritten and has things
crossed out and often there's very
clinically complex information in there
so what we actually do is we use a
combination of Technology and clinically
trained human abstractors to do that and
so we use technology in the form of both
software we develop and then models and
algorithms that we use to surface
exactly the
right information to the right people to
then extract that information in the
clinical context and so once we process
all of this data and standardize it we
then have a combined analytic data set
of research grade data that we can then
use to answer some of these questions
and so flashback to years to me on the
stage giving this talk about my
experience from 2015 when I joined when
it was still a smaller startup that year
we had about 100 to 150 people most of
them or at least of a vast majority were
software engineers the quantitative
sciences team that I was on had one
person when I started and then when I
came and give this talk so it's it's on
YouTube I caught it a statistician walks
into a tech company because I started
this job and I was like where where did
I end up Who am I how did I get here how
do I work in this environment and so
that was the the talk I gave two years
ago about that experience and so over
that year we scaled from about a hundred
to about 250 or more and so over doubled
in size in that one year and the
quantitative Sciences team did grow from
one to ten over the course of that year
but as I mentioned the choice of what
language to use was not clear-cut so the
team coming in at the time actually was
predominantly SAS users in that first
year and so you know I was coming from
an our background and that's really what
I wanted to use but it's just not a
clear-cut announcer of what the best
choice is here and so people did have
some experience with our but this is
their self rate of proficiency at time
of hire for that first year's team and
so some of them had no experience but a
lot were beginners so maybe they had
seen it used it a little bit you know
perhaps alike a lot of people in this
room today who were just getting into
our and so early on some of the the
challenges that we faced in that first
year were the basic things of actually
just which language do we use and this
is an actual list of pros and cons that
my colleague Melissa came up with one
late night we were trying to decide and
she wrote down all the reasons to use
SAS
all the reasons to use our and some of
them were very practical and some of
them were more fun so for sass it made
sense because we collaborated with
pharma companies as a healthcare tech
company and although many of them do use
our there was still used a conception
that a lot of them use SAS we had also
paid money for a license and so we
didn't want to waste all that money and
for her and others in the team it was
intuitive they had experience with it it
felt familiar then on the our side there
were things like the community around
our we thought it aligned with our
values as a company I thought it was the
future we also thought it worked really
well with our tools that we used like
Max and get for version control and then
my favorite reason she had was that the
sweatshirts and the swag we're much
better for our and so she really liked
the sweatshirt and then that night we
made the decision because in a small
company you can just make a decision
like this two people one night and then
we were gonna use are so great decided
then we had to figure out how to
cultivate our culture and we started
things like starting an internal art
package it was really not much to speak
of at all in the beginning but at least
it was the beginning we also started a
user group where we would share
information and knowledge you know we're
gonna tuck that we you'll know you need
a slack channel to do anything so we
started the slack channel for our we
started having trainings and doing
targeted hiring if anybody is in this
stage I would really recommend there's a
blog post from the Airbnb data science
team about using our packages and
education to scale data science and a
lot of these things that we used in that
first year are really covered very well
in a blog post so did these things in
that first year work well if you go from
the time of hire to 2016 when I gave
that last talk here there was a big
change in terms of self rate of
proficiency so people on the team were
starting to call themselves intermediate
and advanced users everybody had started
using our which was a really a big
success and then so enter the next phase
and this is this is what's really
happened in the last two years since I
was here so now we have a very different
team and I
very different size so now the company
has moved from 250 then to over 500 now
and the composition of the team now
actually their primary language at time
of hire was very different so now most
people coming into the team we're using
our before they joined and they were not
beginners or with no experience there
were a lot of advanced and expert users
in fact actually one of the original
data points when I did the survey a few
months ago it said well I thought I was
an expert before I joined and then I
recalibrated and realized I wasn't as
good as I thought so I actually imputed
that as advanced but don't ever tell
anyone I did multiple single imputation
here please and so in that phase over
the last two years you know we've done a
lot of the same things that that we had
done earlier but going to the next stage
so we've instead of just starting this
internal art package we've grown it and
added a lot of functionality and really
tried to cultivate a user group and of
course one slack channels enough not
enough so we need multiple slot channels
and we've started to think about
standardization and having standards for
some of the things that we do quite
often as well as thinking about quality
control and unit tests and with an
emphasis on reproducibility so the work
that we've done has changed a lot since
the beginning so early on we were doing
like a small startup we didn't imagine a
lot of rapid prototyping a lot of quick
analyses in these last two years
actually a lot of our work has gone
towards things like publications or
collaborations with organizations like
the FDA and so when we think about those
things
a quick prototype probably isn't enough
we really need to change the way that
we're doing things and part of the way
that we've done that is having kind of
an agreed upon shared set of packages
that helped us move quickly and so
you'll recognize a lot of these here
this was just a small sample no
coincidence there a lot of them are from
the tidy verse and these help with both
readability and standardization and are
just much better tools to allow us to
move quickly
oh come back to this in a little while
though
when we talk about the trade-offs of
actually having a standard sort of
packages and why that's not always
agreed upon the other package that we've
been using to help us move quickly is
our internal package flatiron R and so
that's the one that we created
internally for a lot of functions for
things like database connections that
that we use here and a lot of
functionality that we use often and of
course it has its own hex ticker because
you know if you really want though
something to be successful that's the
best way to get the message out there
and so some some more about that
internal package so it's things that
have functions that are specific to the
specific data formats that we have
database connections standardizing those
across all of our databases so it's not
you know the most like exciting or sexy
type of functions there but they're
really useful functions that help us
move this faster so we also have things
like for example we work in oncology so
we do a lot of survival analyses and we
have some some kaplan-meier curve
functions that do them in a specific and
standardized way that match our
specifications and actually my colleague
Josh is in the audience and was really
helpful in getting some of those off the
ground
so another thing if anybody has worked
in kind of the biomedical research world
you'll know the the joys and
frustrations of making a table one it's
just basically a table of baseline
characteristics of patients and so
there's nothing too fancy here it's
really looking at just descriptive
statistics about the patient's but you
know you ought to have to do it in a
very specialized format and comparing
the groups and so it's just really nice
to have different kinds of helper
functions to do that and so there's this
really nice package called compare
groups that we use quite a bit and that
allows us to more easily do things that
are specific for this kind of a medical
research environment and so I mentioned
early on that we had some you know
starting to do some work in
collaborations on with companies work
with organizations like the FDA
so early on we had thought actually one
of the reasons to use SAS was there is
this misconception out there that the
FDA only looked at SAS and that they
were against our and you know they had
never actually said that but that's what
people really thought and so one of the
big pieces of pushback we got early on
was oh you can't use our if you ever
want to do anything related to the FDA
well fast forward two years now and
earlier this year we had our first joint
collaborative publication with them come
out and all the analyses we did in our
and it turns out it's really not a big
deal at all and as long as we're using
the right reproducible standards it
hasn't been a problem and a little bit
more about this paper I think because
it's really interesting so this was
actually looking at characteristics of
real-world patients so those are those
ninety-five percent of patients that are
seeing their oncologist but not in a
clinical trial and this is in the
setting of advanced non-small-cell lung
cancer and so looking at those
real-world lung cancer patients compared
to patients in a clinical trial and one
of the things that we found in this
collaboration is that those are very
different types of patients so it's not
just that patients aren't being included
in this research but they're actually
very different in all of these different
ways in patient characteristics and so
what we think is that the studies of
outcomes in these underrepresented
populations through world data are
actually essential for informing
real-world treatment decisions it came
out in January but happy to give you the
reference later so now in 2018 after
this two-year phase this was the
beginning of the year i resurveyed the
team and proficiency with r is now very
high almost everybody rates themselves
at advanced or higher or intermediate
and so i'm not going to necessarily
assume any causality here in terms of
what we did and what happened but i do
think that a lot of the things that we
worked on over time have really helped
with this so are we done have we you
know succeeded is this no more
challenges
well have to tell you now although we
have come so far there are still
challenges that remain and next level
success looks different than what we've
done in the past so early on success was
things like deciding we're gonna use our
and getting sweatshirts now we have what
I think are kind of if I think of them
as grown-up problems to have so these
are the ones that are you know harder to
solve a little bit less fun but our
serious problem is when you get to a
more mature and more scale team and so
going forward for the next two years a
lot of the things that really are really
focusing on now is thinking about
balancing independence with
standardization so the independence
thing is is really twofold so from the
perspective of moving quickly we like to
have teams that can work independently
and it can do things that the way they
want to and just move fast also a lot of
people on the team coming from academic
backgrounds and I think that's really
ingrained and if who we are and how we
think about ourself is no one tells me
how to write my code no one tells me
which packages to use on the other hand
there are a lot of benefits of
standardization both in terms of the
packages that you use and the style that
you write in some of the best practices
and so I think trying to find that
balance of how much specification and
standardization do you need to have you
know we have a draft style guide but not
everybody follows it how much do we have
force it those are some of the questions
that we're tackling right now one of the
biggest questions is how do we find time
to devote to infrastructure and balance
the opportunity cost because we are
growing so quickly every hour that we
spend on thinking about planning and
infrastructure is an hour that we take
away from doing something new and cool
and exciting but as you know it's not
really sustainable to only do those new
cool exciting things if you don't think
about investing and spending down on
technical debt and you know we actually
a few months ago when I did this survey
I asked what is the biggest barrier to
you for contributing more to
our internal package or any of our other
infrastructure or coding culture and the
number one answer it wasn't lack of
desire it wasn't lack of skills or
restrictions and the functions it was
time people want to contribute we just
need to find how to balance the time and
how to protect that so another thing is
thinking about versioning and
maintenance of an internal art package
so once you have a package that's great
but then who is the owner of that
package how do you think about
maintaining it and especially when
you're thinking about working across
multiple teams where the ownership is is
less clear and not everybody has the
same amount of time to devote to it how
do you make that so that's fair and it
also is being maintained and then also I
mentioned earlier a lot of those
stickers that I had up were for tidy
verse packages so we loved them they're
great but should we require people to
use them this is the debate I see in
code reviews all the time going back and
forth someone says oh you should use you
know some tidy verse package here and
suppose like well I'd really like to do
that in base R and so they go back and
forth and it's really hard to know how
much to just encourage verses to enforce
there and so this next phase of growth
so about two months ago my colleague
caught TNI we're thinking about this
with some other folks on the team and we
said you know we are really at a
decision point now we really need to
think about what this next phase of
growth is and change the strategies for
how we figure this out and how we plan
about this going forward so we had a
meeting with the team and we presented
the problem in the motivation so the the
agenda was we talked about some of these
goals that we had then and the goals
that we have now and how they're very
different and need different solutions
and what some of the challenges we face
are and so we did that to get people to
acknowledge that there were new
challenges that we had to address and to
get buy-in and also to get people
excited about what could be the next
stage of this and how to actually be
part of that and so that you know two
years from now if I'm giving a talk
again that they could actually see some
of the work that they did
part of the solution there so we started
a new working group CAUTI my colleague
did and then got started on on planning
and thinking about how where to go from
here and so the first things that this
group has done in the last few months is
starting off with the first set of goals
of defining things like coding standards
and best practices and also it's not
enough to define best practices but
think about how we should hold ourselves
accountable to them and if they should
be enforced and one of the first
standards that they came up with was
thinking about coding readability and
kind of a simple guide of writing their
code with an audience in mind one of the
things that came up often is that the
code that one might write for an
analysis is very different than a code
and a software engineer might write for
something in production and thinking
about actually telling the story laying
out the assumptions thinking about all
of the things that go into the analysis
as part of how they write the code and
next is thinking about these best
practices you know how do you actually
integrate those into culture so it's not
like you're just telling someone to do
something but it's actually part of
something that people want to do and you
know the last we're gonna get some new
stickers because that is really
motivating and so rather than the
stickers we had before that everybody
got and I think this this idea might
have come from the Airbnb data science
team or another data science team I'm
sure of actually only giving them out to
people who are contributing certain
things and the the core group so to have
that kind of motivation and you know
thinking about there's a lot of
challenges around package and
environment management that are gonna be
coming up in the future that we want to
tackle and so just want to thank
everybody on both the team the current
past and future members and in
particular this working group that my
colleague caught - you just spun up and
that's thinking about some of these
next-level grown-up challenges and also
our other collaborators in the art
community and then just a shameless plug
that we are still growing we might
double in size again so please get in
touch with me if you're interested in
joining thank you
you
you